the trump administration doubles down on
the trade war with china
democrats defend anti-semitism as usual
and bill nye lectures americans about
global warming i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
righty a lot to get to today a lot in
the news we'll get to all of it in just
a second first
vitamins supplements these things can be
confusing persona they take the
guesswork out of it one of our employees
here at the daily wire jared he takes
persona vitamins in the morning and in
the evening
he filled out the online assessment he
indicated he wanted the vegetarian
formula
some of the personalized supplements in
his order include green tea extract for
energy support
and digestive enzymes as part of the
happy gut formula the packaging it comes
in is sleek simple
innovative there are separate packs for
every morning and every evening so you
know exactly what you need to take each
and every day so here's how you get
started you take a three to five minute
assessment and find out exactly what you
need
you get recommendations based on your
goals lifestyle allergies special diets
prescription meds convenient vitamin
packets are then delivered to your door
every month
persona checks for over 850 medications
against their database of supplements
and they recommend that is to ensure
that there are no negative interactions
persona offers over 90 different
supplements which create 5 trillion
possible combinations
they personalize your recommendation
specifically for you again someone on my
team jared he uses persona
he loves it i've looked at all of the
specs on the website it's really easy
you're going to love it as well right
now
whether you want to sleep better have
more energy or simply stay as young as
you can
my listeners can go to
personanutrition.comshapiro
that's p e r s o n a nutrition dot com
shapiro get 50 off your order today it's
five minutes that can change
your health persona nutrition dot com
shapiro get 50
off your order today alrighty so the big
story of the day and really the big
story of the last
several months is the fact that the
united states is effectively in a trade
war with china i know this is boring
stuff i know people don't want to talk
about trade policy
they don't really want to talk about the
economy when the economy seems to be
booming but the fact is that if there is
one factor
that is going to impact the 2020
election that nobody is talking about
it is the possibility of a trade war
with china now as i have said
there are two ways of viewing this trade
war with china way number one
president trump is playing chicken with
the chinese he is trying to
emphasize over and over and over that
tariffs are wonderful tariffs are fine
because he's trying to get china to
crumble
he's trying to put a brick on the
accelerator in this game of chicken
and demonstrate that he has
pre-committed to doing whatever he has
to do to get them to cave
that's possibility number one
possibility number two is that
president trump actually kind of likes
tariffs now the reason that possibility
number two
is probably more probable is because
over the course of trump's career he's
been very clear that he likes tariffs he
likes the idea of using trade barriers
he thinks that economies are stronger
when you put up protective barriers
around domestic industry now this
happens not to be true
economics 101 teaches you that if you
are to prevent the importation of
cheaper products and cheaper inputs from
other places
you're actually taxing your own
consumers think about this in your own
daily life
let's say that you run a carpentry shop
and let's say that there's a grocery
in town and you spend a lot of money at
the grocery every month but they are not
buying your goods
now theoretically you could say to the
grocery list i'm not going to shop at
your grocery
until you start buying the kind of
shelves that i build
and maybe that works in which case that
was a good use of tariffs
maybe instead or it is possible
that if they are not going to buy your
carpentry anyway
or if they have no intention of doing so
or being pressured into it all you are
doing by refusing to buy from the
grocery
is making sure that you're going to
spend more money on groceries you
haven't damaged them
you've really only hurt yourself you've
hurt them a little bit you've hurt
yourself a lot more because in terms of
relative cost
depriving your consumers of cheaper
products and better products
is a way of damaging your tax paying
base that's exactly what happens
when you tariff a country so there
better be another reason that you are
actually
using the tariff it can't just be for
the purpose of strengthening the economy
now the problem that i have with
president trump's talk about tariffs is
that it fails to acknowledge
the reality the reality is that every
tariff must be a game of chicken or it
is just damaging to domestic industry
if you're just tariffing other countries
all you are doing is forcing your
taxpayers to
pay higher prices for products that are
imported or for competitive goods
produced in the united states
that no longer have to lower their price
to compete with those foreign
imports so for example president trump
he says listen we're in a very good
position everything is fine
everything's gonna be fine tariffs are
great the bottom line is
uh we are taking in tremendous amounts
of money
it already started as of last friday but
it really started seven months before
that
it's in the form of tariffs or taxes and
it had a tremendous impact if you looked
at the first quarter which is always
historically the worst
quarter we were 3.2 percent people were
very surprised well a lot of that was
the tariffs that we were taking in from
china so we're in a very good position
and i think it's only going to get
better hey the idea that we are making
money hand over thanks to tariffs is
simply not true the tax is actually not
on chinese producers
the tax is on american consumers
president trump has been tweeting out
consistently about this and inaccurately
about this
he tweeted out in one year tariffs have
rebuilt our steel industry it is booming
we placed a 25 tariff on dumped steel
from china and other countries
and we now have a big and growing
industry we had to save steel for our
defense and auto industries both of
which
are coming back strong so first of all
steel tariffs actually harm the auto
industry because the auto industry
prefers to have cheaper steel rather
than more expensive steel
as for the idea that we have to have
steel capacity for our defense
we do have steel capacity we had steel
capacity before the tariffs
and it was plenty for our defense
finally as
as far as the notion that the tariffs
placed on the steel industry of china
have somehow benefited american domestic
producers in steel
there's not a lot of evidence to support
that according to the new york times as
of january
in the 10 months since the trump
administration imposed 25
steel tariffs on steel imports prices in
the united states have fallen back to
levels last seen
before the tariffs were announced on
march 1st hiring in the steel sector
remained stagnant
in part because new mills have become
reliant on automation
even with the opening and restarting of
several mills last year direct steel
industry employment was 146
000 people as of november 4 lower than
it was four years ago
according to the american iron and steel
institute industry analysts estimate
that steel companies
estimate that steel companies made 50
announcements and plans for new mills
and investments last year
and that three dozen plants were built
or restarted
but investors are increasingly wary of
the industry's long-term strength
because stock prices are in fact
dropping they drop by as much as 47
in 2018 amid fears of slowing global
economic growth
it doesn't matter if you're protecting a
domestic industry if there's nobody who
has the money to buy your stuff
trade wars in fact are generally not
good or easy to win
and beijing has more of an interest
frankly in
demonstrating strength than the united
states does
because the fact is that it is a
communist party regime
that requires the fear of its people in
order to move forward that means that
at the very least if they're going to
make concessions they have to save face
if they were just to surrender to
president trump they're going to look
bad in front of their own folks
according to newstimes.com the u.s the
u.s trade war continues to heat up with
beijing
calling for a people's war against
washington and president trump
threatening to impose tariffs on another
300 billion dollars worth
of chinese goods in a series of
editorials and op-ed articles published
on monday
chinese state media slammed what it
labeled the trump administration's greed
and arrogance and called for a people's
war against it
beijing's state-run media effectively
serves as a mouthpiece for the communist
party
the important thing is that in the u.s
china trade war the u.s sides with greed
greed and arrogance and morale will
break at any point the chinese side is
fighting back to protect its legitimate
interests
according to the nationalistic global
times tabloid which is effectively a
government newspaper
over there the trade war in the us is
the creation of one person and one
administration but it affects that
country's entire population
in china the entire country and all its
people are being threatened for us this
is a real
people's war now maybe the idea is that
this war is worthwhile
and that there will be domestic costs
but we should understand that china is
in fact an international threat that's
an argument i am very warm to
that's an argument that i sort of agree
with and that is also an argument that
is being made by senator tom cotton of
arkansas who's at least being honest
with the american people about what's
going on
tariffs are not good for the american
economy they are not good for american
domestic producers this is particularly
true in the farming industry
american farmers are feeling it right on
the chin because our chief exports to
china
is indeed farming stuffs soybeans
corn and that's the sort of stuff so
senator cotton
at least makes a solid case his case is
listen we're going to feel
some temporary pain but that temporary
pain is in service of a long-term goal
that's being honest i prefer honesty for
my politicians here senator cotton
so these tariffs are going to end up
hurting both chinese
and some americans i'll grant you that i
think they'll ultimately hurt the
chinese more than they will americans in
part because chinese
companies and their government have been
cheating the united states for so long
there will be some sacrifice
on the part of americans i grant you
that but i also would say that sacrifice
is pretty minimal
compared to the sacrifices that our
soldiers make overseas that are fallen
heroes who are laid to rest in arlington
make
okay well obviously that is that is true
i think that if you're going to talk
about
china and tariffing them you need to
talk about the threat that china
actually presents on a global scale
that's something that trump has not yet
sold to the american people so if there
is an economic downturn due to the
tariffs trump is going to feel it on the
chin politically
he's endangering his own presidency
without making a very solid case for why
these tariffs are necessary
and if they aren't necessary then just
make the case
trump continues to promote the idea that
tariffs are good he says china buys much
less from us than we buy from them by
almost 500 billion dollars so we are in
a fantastic position
make your product at home in the usa and
there is no tariff you can also buy from
a non-tariff country instead of china
many companies are leaving china so they
will be more competitive for u.s buyers
we are in a much bigger economy than
china and have substantially increased
in size since the great 2016 election
we are the piggy bank everyone wants to
raid and take advantage of
no more well again tariffs are a way of
raiding the piggy bank on behalf of
certain protected industries
in the united states unless you're
making the case that we are in effect
in a de facto foreign conflict with
china in which case sacrifices must be
made but you got to make that case
trump says we can make a deal with china
tomorrow before their companies start
leaving so as not to use
lose usa business but the last time we
were close they wanted to renegotiate
the deal no way
we are in a much better position now
than any deal we could have made we'll
be taking in billions of dollars and
moving jobs back to usa where they
belong
other countries are already negotiating
with us because they don't want this to
happen to them
they must be part of usa action this
should have been done by our leaders
many years ago enjoy now it's worthwhile
pointing out here that if you actually
want to create a trade quarter around
china there was something
that was called the trans-pacific
partnership there were flaws in it as
negotiated by the obama administration
but simply ducking out of the
trans-pacific partnership which was a
trade bloc designed to
to foil china there's a bunch of
countries near china but not including
china
dumping that actually gave china a
regional advantage in making one-on-one
deals with countries that surround it
trump says when the time is right we
will make a deal with china my respect
and friendship with president xi is
unlimited
but as i have told him many times before
this must be a great deal for the united
states or just doesn't make any sense
we have to be allowed to make up some of
the tremendous ground we have lost to
china on trade
since the ridiculous one-sided formation
of the wto it will all happen
much faster than people think and then
he gets
to what is i think his most ridiculous
contention we'll get to that in just one
second first
no one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy i'm busy who's got
time for all that traffic parking
logging all your
mail-in packages it is a real hassle and
that's why you need stamps.com it's one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts you can't get
at the post office stamps.com brings all
the amazing services of the us postal
service
right to your computer whether you're a
small office sending invoices an online
seller shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in the mailbox it is indeed
that simple
with stamps.com you get five cents off
every first class stamp
and up to 40 off priority mail not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters so
stamps.com is a no-brainer it saves you
time it saves you money there's a reason
i use it personally there's a reason we
use it here at the dailywire offices
because we like to be smart and
efficient
it's no wonder over 700 000 small
businesses already use stamps.com
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
enter shapiro go check it out right now
enter code shapiro alright so president
trump's
most ridiculous statement about this
this trade war again a case can be made
for the trade war but you first have to
explain why we are effectively at war
with china and then why the american
people must make sacrifices
instead president trump keeps promoting
the idea that everything is fine and
that's whistling past the economic grave
here
trump says our great patriot farmers
will be one of the biggest beneficiaries
of what is happening now
hopefully china will do us the honor of
continuing to buy our great farm product
the best
but if not your country will be making
up the difference based on a very high
china buy
this money will come from the massive
tariffs being paid to the united states
for allowing china and others to do
business with us
the farmers have been forgotten for many
years their time is now
okay that's that's a hard sell right
here because u.s farmers are feeling the
brunt of this so what is trump going to
do use
american taxpayer dollars to pay
subsidies to farmers
according to the associated press
china's announcement on monday of higher
tariffs
on 60 billion dollars of american
exports hit particularly hard in the
farm belt
these are the areas specifically that
president trump does need to win
in 2020 if he hopes to retain the
presidency
since december when u.s and china
negotiators called it truce to tariffs
and began signaling an agreement might
be reached
soybean farmers had been holding out
hope that sales to china would resume
the farmers had been storing a record
stockpile of nearly 1 billion bushels
the latest round of new tariffs spooked
the financial markets and some farmers
who have been tentatively optimistic
in a statement on monday the american
soybean association said quote
that they said that they reacted with
frustration edged with anxiety
john heisdorfer a soybean farmer in iowa
who's chairman of the asa said quote the
sentiments out in the farm country is
getting grimmer by the day
our patience is waning our finances are
suffering and the stress from months of
living with the consequences of these
tariffs
is mounting the fifth year of low prices
basically for crops
according to many of these farmers so
president trump if you're going to make
the case that americans ought to
sacrifice you have to explain what
exactly
they are sacrificing for otherwise
president trump runs into the danger
of seeming enthusiastic about a policy
that is actually
harming americans in a very serious way
if you want americans to make a
sacrifice explain why they are making
the sacrifice
if not then expect to feel the political
brunt
of all of this okay with all of that
said
the democratic party continues to push
forward with its own
radicalism their latest evidence of
radicalism is the defense
of rashida talib so the the democratic
party is quickly becoming the jeremy
corbyn party
in great britain they're quickly
becoming a labour party they are willing
to defend
anything so long as it is said by an
intersectional woke personality
today's example is not representative
ilhan omar who continues to say
anti-semitic things
every five minutes and 37 seconds or so
but rashida talib
who way back in december november of
last year suggested that all supporters
of israel
suffered from dual loyalty and were
actually loyal to israel not to the
united states
and then over the weekend she was on a
yahoo news podcast where she explained
that she is very proud of palestinian
behavior during the holocaust and that
israel only exists because of the
holocaust a lot of people are saying
that this is not anti-semitic it's just
a historical that's the case
being made by michael oren the former
uh israeli ambassador to the united
nations
i think he is wrong i will explain why
here's rashida talib and here's what she
says
there's you know there's a kind of a
calming feeling i always tell folks
when i think of the holocaust and the
tragedy of the holocaust
and the fact that it was my ancestors
palestinians
who lost their land and some lost their
lives their livelihood the human dignity
their existence in many ways have been
wiped out and some people's passport i
mean just
all of it was in the name of trying to
create a safe haven ju
for jews post the holocaust post the
tragedy and horrific
um persecution of jews
across the world at that time and
i love the fact that it was my ancestors
that provided that right
in many ways okay her ancestors did not
provide any of that
this is a historical it's a historical
in the extreme and in its a-historicity
it supports an anti-semitic narrative
that is being pushed by rashida to leave
and others the anti-semitic narrative
goes something like this the jews have
no inherent connection to the land of
israel
the jews are in fact basically a
group of parasites who were given this
place in the middle east on the backs of
palestinians who suffered
specifically because of the mass murder
of jews in germany and the palestinians
are the true victims
when it comes to world history because
the world cared about the jews enough to
give them a place in the middle of
palestinian land
jews could have been put anywhere but
they were put there specifically because
the world didn't care about the
palestinians right this is the narrative
that she is attempting to push
and the palestinians were kind-hearted
and then israel abused them all of this
is sure nonsense that's an anti-semitic
narrative because it is not not only is
it not true
it is designed at the extermination of
the state of israel a cause that rashida
talib
supports she's in favor of this of a
so-called one-state solution
in which all the palestinians as well as
any quote-unquote palestinian refugees
from abroad
go back to the land of israel and then
are given full citizenship rights to
vote many of these people have never set
foot in the state of israel many of them
are syrian many of them are egyptian
the idea would be the destruction of the
state of israel as a jewish state the
only jewish state
on planet earth now as michael lawrence
says it's
historical but it's not just a
historical it is whitewashing
palestinian behavior
during and before the holocaust and that
is what this is
israel and the jewish connection with
the land of israel goes back 3000 years
that is nothing new it was not created
in the aftermath of the holocaust
not only that but it was palestinian
arab intransigence that led to the
slaughter
of hundreds of thousands of jews who are
attempting to escape europe palestinian
arabs tried to force
the british mandate to refuse the the
acceptance
of jewish refugees from europe into
british mandate
palestine leading the way was it was
muhammad al-husseini okay this would be
the the grand mufti
of jerusalem the grand mufti of
jerusalem
was a was a nazi ally in the middle of
the
holocaust a a letter was written by
heinrich himmler the ss commander who's
responsible for the implementation of
the holocaust
and he wrote him this letter to the
grand mufti amin al-husseini
the national socialist movement of the
greater german reich has since its
inception upheld the fight against world
jewry
it is for this reason that it closely
follows the struggle of the
freedom-seeking arabs and particularly
in palestine
against the jewish invaders the common
recognition of the enemy and the joint
struggle against it
is what creates the firm foundation
between germany and freedom-seeking
muslims around the world
in this spirit i am pleased to convey to
you on the anniversary of the
excremental ball for declaration which
is a recognition
that there was a a state of israel in
the works
since 1917 legally warm wishes for your
continued struggle
until the great victory rex fewer ss
heinrich himmler
that's hajime al-husseini hussaini
visited germany he sat down with hitler
if you're watching the video you can
actually see pictures of him sitting
with hitler
standing and saluting all the german
troops giving the heil hitler
han salute this this was the leader
of the palestinian population in the
middle of world war ii
and long before world war ii because in
april 1920
as is written by edie cohen over at
thetower.org in april 1920 the
victorious allied powers convened in
san remo italy to negotiate a peace
treaty with turkey
as a direct result britain was handed
the mandate for palestine previously
domain of the ottoman empire with the
understanding that london would now make
good on its commitment to a jewish
national home
as underlined by the balfour declaration
in november of 1917.
in 1919 hajime al-husseini a prominent
sion of the al-husseini clan which was
agitating for violent conflict against
the jews and the british
began organizing small groups of
terrorists to harass and attack
palestine's jews one year later as the
allies were debating
at san remo al-husseini instigated
anti-jewish riots in jerusalem
during the intermediate days of the
passover festival six jews murdered more
than 200 wounded during an orgy of
destruction
the british arrested him but a year
later the newly installed british high
commissioner herbert samuel eager to
dampen tensions
pardoned al husseini and appointed him
to the post of grand mufti of jerusalem
samuel could not have been more wrong as
a direct consequence of britain's
empowerment of him as mufti al-husseini
was emboldened
in pursuing the aim of violently
removing the jewish presence in
palestine
over the following two decades all
hussein is hardened to anti-semitic
worldview together with his
determination to extinguish any prospect
of the balfour declaration's promise
from being realized
made him a natural middle eastern ally
of germany's nazi regime
once once it launched its war of
conquest and genocide
in 1939 within three weeks of his first
meeting with samuel al-husseini
orchestrated riots in patakhtikvah and
yafo
which resulted in the murders of 43 jews
this continued
four years and because of his
because of his stumping against the jews
the british colonial secretary malcolm
mcdonald issued an infamous white paper
in may
1939 that set britain's policy on the
course of appeasing arab desires
denounced in the house of commons by
winston churchill
as a moral blow the white paper limited
jewish entry into british palestine
to 75 000 over the next five years on
the eve of the holocaust and then all
husseini
pledged support for the nazis and
pledged support effectively for the
holocaust and encouraged hitler
to actually engage in a holocaust in the
middle east if hitler were to conquer
british palestine al-husseini
was an evil piece of human debris an
evil evil man
and he was also instrumental in the
launch of an arab war of extermination
against the nascent jewish state
in 1947 and 1948. that is the actual
history here so
is what talib said anti-semitic i'll
explain in just a second first
we the people holsters offer custom-made
holsters all produced in the united
states they design their own holsters
in-house that means they don't use any
third-party
molds for their holsters instead they
design every single unique mold in las
vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly
they constantly update designs they add
new designs every month and that lets
them stay up to date on the newest
models that come out
we the people holsters even have their
own 3d design team who measures every
micro millimeter of their guns to ensure
the perfect fit
their unique intuitive clip design
allows for you to easily adjust both the
cans and the ride of your holster so
it'll fit comfortably and securely at
all times every holster also has an
adjustable retention which is signaled
with a click sound and that lets you
know that your firearm is securely in
place which is pretty important
you ever want more tension you tighten
one screw you're done custom printed
designs in-house
thin blue line thin red line
constitution camouflage and american
flag
and more come out every single month we
the people holsters they start at just
37 bucks a piece and every holster comes
with a lifetime guarantee which is a
great price for a lifetime guaranteed
fantastic holster
every holster ships free if it's not a
perfect fit you send it back for a
refund
i myself own a smith and wesson nine
millimeter and i have a we the people
holster it is fantastic right now
listeners of the ben shapiro show can go
to wethepeopleholsters.com
ben enter promo code ben at checkout to
get 10
off their first holster that's as low as
37 bucks shipping is free with an
additional 10 bucks off so 27 bucks
using my promo code again that's we the
peopleholsters.com
ben promo code ben at checkout for 10
off okay so
what talib says is deeply ahistorical
but it's not just
a historical okay let's imagine that
there is an american politician
and they were talking about the
institution of slavery in the united
states
and what they actually said is i'm just
so grateful
to the slaveholders of the south because
if it weren't for the slaveholders of
the south then black people in america
never would have gained their freedom
if it weren't for brutal slaveholders in
the south you know whipping slaves
separating families
treating people as property then blacks
never would have been able to gain their
freedom
you would say okay that's not just a
historical you are now whitewashing some
of the most evil people
to have lived in the united states well
that's what talib is doing
and she's not only doing that she's also
she's also
attempting to pretend that there is no
connection between
the jews and the state of israel now
this has become a common left trope
is that the holocaust is the only reason
that there is a jewish state of israel
again that is a historical nonsense the
ball for declaration in 1917 pledged a
jewish state that by the way included
jordan
originally and so that that pre-existed
the holocaust by a solid three decades
nonetheless that that push is to
delegitimize the state of israel and
claim that the real owners of the land
are the palestinians who never had a
state in the region there was never an
independent state of palestine
an independent arab state of palestine
it was always dominated by the ottoman
empire there was no idea
of quote unquote palestinian identity
palestinian era by density
palestinians historically speaking were
actually known as jews
the palestine post was the original name
for the jerusalem post
so that's not to say they weren't
inhabitants of the land of israel
who were arabs there were but there were
also inhabitants of the land of israel
who were jews and when it came time for
the divvying of the land
the the land of jordan was given to the
arabs the west bank and gaza strip were
originally given
to the arabs that deal was accepted by
the jews it was rejected by the arabs
and
several wars of extermination have been
launched by the arab states surrounding
israel
ever since so when she attempts to wipe
out the jewish nature of the state of
israel
understand that this is part of a
broader agenda that rashida talib has
been pursuing
in coordination with her boycott
divestment sanctions support
okay now you have to know that because
we have to parse what she said that's
anti-semitic from what she said that is
not anti-semitic so people are jumping
on some of the language that she uses in
that quote right people are jumping i
think incorrectly on the language that
she uses with regard to quote unquote
she feels a calming aspect with regard
to the holocaust now i don't think
honestly speaking that she was saying
that the holocaust calms her
i don't think that's what she is saying
there i think it's pretty obvious from
her verbiage that what she is actually
saying
is that she feels a calming notion
about how palestinians have been treated
when she creates this fictional history
in her head
in which palestinian arabs were
wonderfully welcoming to jews and didn't
seek to exterminate them
as soon as the jewish state of israel
was created and frankly before
right so her false sense of history
allows her to believe that that
she and her ancestors were the good guys
in this particular narrative
and that's calming to her i don't think
that she's saying that the holocaust is
calming but the narrative is itself
supportive of an anti-semitic narrative
and she knows that she knows that so
this led president trump to tweet
about it and he tweeted uh he tweeted
democrat representative talib
is being slammed for her horrible and
highly insensitive statement on the
holocaust
she obviously has tremendous hatred of
israel and the jewish people can you
imagine what would happen if i ever said
what she said
and says this is eminently correct what
president trump says
is totally correct here okay and then
liz cheney tweets house republican
surely now speaker pelosi and leader
hoyer will finally take action against
the vile anti-semitism in their ranks
this must cross the line even for them
rashida talib says thinking of the
holocaust provides her
a calming feeling okay now this is less
accurate so president trump's tweet is
more accurate
liz cheney's tweet is taking talib out
of context that doesn't change the fact
that what talib said is anti-semitic but
that is pointing out anti-semitism where
it doesn't exist in the quote and
ignoring anti-semitism where it does
exist
in the quote but overall is rashida to
leave an anti-semite of course she's an
anti-semite
she's she's not been hiding this she
very early on in her in her tenure
she posted a picture from her office of
a post-it note on a map
that pointed to the entire land of
israel and said palestine
she invited people who are for the
complete destruction of the state of
israel
to her inauguration to her swearing-in
there's there's a bunch of articles
online about all of her immediate
friends
and what they have to say about the
state of israel this is certainly
somebody who is extraordinarily
comfortable in the context
of anti-semitism and you can see how
comfortable she is tamika mallory
defended rashida talib tamika mallory
uh is herself an anti-semite who meets
with louis farrakhan who who defends
louis farrakhan she says leave her she
did it to leave alone she fights hard
every day she's full of passion
and a commitment to the most
marginalized people the kind of leader
we need
and then rashida talib tweets back the
fist emoji we can't allow the gop
to silence us nobody's trying to silence
rashida to leap she can say whatever she
wants
i think she should say whatever she
wants i think the democratic party
should be exposed for the pandering
fools they are
when it comes to this particular issue
but the fact that that she's retweeting
an open anti-semite like tamika mallory
kind of says what you need to say and
then of course you have ilhan omar
coming out and defending she tweets out
you praised people at a neo-nazi rally
this is what she says about
president trump we don't have to imagine
okay so even that cuts against her point
so president trump did not in fact
praise neo-nazis and white supremacists
he did not okay he actually denounced
them
at that famous charlottesville press
conference my criticism of president
trump on charlottesville
is that he was not clear in his original
in his original statement and then in
his follow-up statement
he himself created a historical fiction
where there were these wonderful people
who were marching with the white
supremacists at charlottesville but he
did not in fact
praise the neo-nazis but ilhan omar's
statement even if we take it at face
value does
not prove her point right trump is
saying imagine what would happen if i
said something similar
and she says we don't have to imagine
you did say something similar
right there's blanket media coverage and
for three years all
we have heard is that president trump is
basically a neo-nazi supporter and yet
el hanomar is making the case that if
rashida talib says the same thing we
should not treat her similarly
and then el hanomar goes exactly where
she always goes this is islamophobia so
if you quote
roshita taliba accurately and you
accurately characterize her statements
then this is a form of islamophobia he
says this
she says this is another transparent
attempt to sow division between minority
communities and distract from your own
criminal behavior by smearing a muslim
woman okay again
if we are talking about sowing division
between minority communities namely
muslims and jews which i assume she's
talking about here
and the person sewing divisions would be
anti-semites like gilhan amar and people
like rashida talib
and the democratic leadership so nancy
pelosi comes out in defense
of all of this so does steiny hoyer both
of them suggest
that president trump ought to apologize
to rashida talib which is
an insane contention steiny hoyer
defended talib also
basically they are picking on the
republicans who went too far
by focusing on the calming aspect of the
of the quote from rashida talib and they
are ignoring the fact that rashida talib
actually did say something that is so
historical as to amount to part of an
anti-semitic narrative which is which is
accurate
speaker pelosi said republicans
desperate attempts to smear
representative rashida and misrepresents
her comments
are outrageous president trump should
apologize to representative talib
so it's pretty obvious that the
democrats have decided to completely
fall for the fall for the rules here
they are now they're now in for a penny
and they're in for a pound that means
that no matter what talib says no matter
what omar says i mean there they bought
a ticket and they're going to take the
ride
and they ought to take the ride because
they are backing anti-semite open
anti-semites at this point
now if american jews choose not to see
that that says more about their
commitment
to judaism than it does about the health
of the democratic party
if you are a member of a party that is
consistently rooting for and covering
for people who call for the
extermination
of the largest group identity
that is possible inside your group right
the state of israel is the jewish state
it is the
it is the greatest collective of jews on
planet earth right now
if you are okay with that then that says
more about you than it does about the
democratic party so don't quote to me oh
well many jews are going to continue to
vote for the democratic party i don't
care
that doesn't change the principle at
stake that's a that's an absurd defense
the democratic party has chosen where it
stands on all of it so the media by the
way in a second i'm going to show you
seth meyers who demonstrates just what a
pathetic hack he is we'll get to that in
just one second first
go over to dailywire.com for 9.99 a
month you can
get a subscription to dailywire.com when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get two additional hours of the
show
every afternoon we are we are working
our fingers to the bone for you
and so you should go check us out over
there also you can get our sunday
specials on saturday we have great
sunday special coming up this week i
can't announce who the guest is
suffice it to say it's pretty awesome
you can check that out you get a day
early you get extra questions behind the
paywall
you get to ask me questions during the
mailbag segments all sorts of goodies
plus
in july we're bringing all sorts of new
goodies i can't even tell you about
those unless my business partner get
angry at me but you should go check that
out as well
9.99 a month or 99 or you get this the
leftist year is hot or cold tumbler
you can see it you can cast your visage
upon it you can enjoy it
go check it out right now so do all of
those things also subscribe at youtube
and
itunes give us a listen give us a review
we always appreciate we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
alrighty so let's talk for a second
about the media coverage of rashida
talib so it's pretty obvious where the
media in the united states stand
where they stand is on the side of
democrats even if those democrats are
endorsing
anti-semitism okay the washington post
here's their headline house republicans
criticized representative to leave over
remarks on holocaust
israel every time democrats say
something terrible
the media cover it as republicans
respond to x
every time democrats do something really
bad it's republicans pounds
this is a point of high irritation for
most republicans as well it should be it
is vile
the fact that so many members of the
media are more focused on republican
responses to bad things that are said
then they're focused on the comments
themselves
is demonstrative of exactly where the
media stand i don't remember a single
headline
that said democrats pounce on
representative steve king
after comments on race i don't remember
a single headline like that it was all
steve king says something
insane and ridiculous and disgusting
about white nationalism right that's all
the headlines were
so they're accurate when it comes to
republicans they're wildly inaccurate
when it comes to democrats
has a democrat ever said something that
is worthy of its own headline or is the
only thing that matters attacking
republicans for attacking democrats
the fact the media continue to play this
game it makes their game absolutely
clear
it's all gotcha politics designed to
come after one side of the political
aisle which unfortunately
is all too common in the left media it's
not honest conversation about what
people have actually said and what they
are actually attempting to say
instead it is an attempt all too often
to cast aspersions
at the conservative side of the aisle
and it's
it's not just it's not just the
washington post it's seth meyer so seth
meyers
just a week ago had on megan mccain and
he tried to browbeat her he called her
an islamophobe for quoting ilhanamar
he suggested that she was responsible
for incitement against ilhan amar now i
have some personal stake in this sort of
thing
i've had a rough couple of weeks
particularly because of this fbi arrest
of a person who's threatening to shoot
me and my family in the head
i don't remember a single article or
question about quote unquote incitement
against me
and as i said and have been saying i
don't think that
you can charge someone with quote
unquote incitement against me even if
they're saying nasty things about me
unless they are openly calling for
violence or implying that people should
do me violence
and yet i don't remember anybody on the
left saying any of those things
the left will say that ilhan omar says
she's getting threats therefore it's
donald trump's fault therefore
islamophobia
megan mccain why can't you behave better
you and your quotes
how dare you seth meyers has become a
full-time democratic party hack
i remember when he was supposed to be a
comedian now he is hosting rashida talib
on her worldwide
anti-semitism defense tour here's
rashida talib explaining
that in reality she has to just speak to
people
as though they're really stupid so
people so racists understand her
i want all of us to feel safe all of us
deserve human dignity
no matter our backgrounds no matter
ethnicity no matter even our
political opinions we all need deserve
that kind of equality and justice
and uh you know for me i wanted to
uplift that and and bring that to light
and
it was unfortunate you know i got a text
message from a friend who's like hey
next time you know really clarify
maybe talk like a fourth fourth grader
because maybe the racist idiots would
understand you better
oh yeah next time you have to clarify
speak like speak like a child so that
the racist idiot here's the thing every
fourth grader understands what rashida
talib is doing
she's engaging in anti-semitic slur she
always engages in anti-semitic slurs
this is part of her stick
this is also true for alejandra the fact
that seth meyers has her on and then
defends her
and talks about how she's the victim
tells you what you need to know about
seth meyers about
about late night tv about stephen
colbert about jimmy kimmel
the media are so stacked in favor of the
democratic party that they
they cannot root out anyone in their
midst it's funny i have a friend
on the left who writes for a leftist
publication and i think that she
tends to be an intellectually honest
person even though she and i disagree on
politics a lot
i don't even think she would describe
herself as part of the left that's my
characterization not hers
but she is constantly talking about how
the republican party does a bad job of
rooting out its own
the republican party can always do a
better job of finding people
who are saying bad things and then
forcing them to back down
or rooting them out but has the
democratic party ever done that
ever i mean really ever when's the last
time the democratic party
said that someone had said something so
vile they had to go the only example i
can think of really is cynthia mckinney
and that was way back in the early 2000s
so it's been about 20 years
since the democratic party actually
cared
about taking people who said terrible
things and then casting them out
now they're more interested in embracing
those people for the sake of
intersectional identity politics than
they are
in making sure that their party actually
represents fundamentally good principles
that's why the democratic party is
defending rashida talib and that's why
seth meyers
and his claptor routine is not even
laughter anymore it's just clapped her
and people clapping for him with few
laughs that's why his routine is
becoming increasingly popular
it's a woke off on late night television
and that's why you have seth meyers
attacking megan mccain who does a good
job and praising rasheeda talib who is
an anti-semite okay meanwhile the
democratic party
continues to push more and more radical
proposals
their best hope at the white house in
2020 is again an implosion by president
trump
not that the american people are ready
to embrace these ideas bernie sanders
is desperately flailing for attention
since joe biden jumped into the race
he has been sinking in the polling
numbers there's a new poll out today
that shows that young support
for bernie sanders is beginning to wane
which is why elizabeth warren
is starting to is starting to think
about
the possibility of gaining the
nomination or at least a vp
nomination according to a new morning
console poll sanders is support among
people between the ages of 18 and 29
has dropped from 45 in march all the way
down to 33
in may that's devastating for him if he
loses that young support i'd always
assume that his support was durable if
that support ends up not being durable
that's a serious problem for him where
is that support going
well apparently virtually all of it is
going to joe biden
biden continues to basically run a very
quiet campaign he is not gaffing very
often
all he has to do is shut up and wait for
the other democrats to kill each other
and that seems to be what is happening
at this point i'm surprised that other
democrats aren't attacking biden
already but biden is is right now the
front runner
so bernie flailing for attention he
continues to say things like he wants to
get rid of the private insurance
industry entirely in healthcare
you're talking about medicare for all
you're in the second largest insurance
capital in the country here in des
moines and a lot of people
there are people who would like to keep
their private insurance
is that possible under that plan no i
think right now
what we should appreciate is that every
year many many
millions of people lose their health
insurance because they
leave their jobs or because
their employer changes their insurance
policies
i think what most americans feel is that
medicare
currently which applies to people 65
years of age or older
is a very strong program it is a popular
program
okay so he continues to push an agenda
that most americans are simply not going
to embrace also
he is now pushing for a credit card
interest rate cap
limit which makes no economic sense i
understand that it's pandering
and i understand that free stuff for
everybody is basically his agenda but
the fact that both he and aoc
are now pushing for the idea that you
are going to cap
credit card interest rates it's it's a
disastrously stupid idea
and even folks at cnn are saying so
okay the diego's luaga he's a policy
analyst at cato institute so he's a
conservative but he's writing for cnn
business
he says back in the early 1900s
progressives helped drive loan sharks
out of business by lobbying to lift
state usury caps those caps had barred
lenders from charging interest rates
above six to ten percent a year
forcing low-income americans to seek
credit in the illegal market
now alexandra ocasio-cortez and bernie
sanders want to bring back a similar
usury law and that's exactly what will
happen
all that will happen is that low-income
people who have bad credit will not be
able to get any credit the reason you
charge a high interest rate is because
you believe there will be default
if you don't believe there will be
default then i can shop around for the
lowest interest rate
you want to destroy the credit markets
this is a pretty easy way to do so
all this stuff most democratic policy at
this point is popular on the surface and
then if you scratch it with a thumbnail
then it is unpopular underneath the same
thing is true
with regard to joe biden and his new
push for environmental revolution
according to the new york times joe
biden defended his record on climate
change on monday
and called for a green revolution that
is rational and affordable
he also talked about breaking up big
companies like facebook
and he derided president trump's tariffs
he said he was speaking at a new
hampshire pizza restaurant
he pledged to deliver a major speech in
detail by the end of may outlining his
environmental
policies he says there's a need for an
environmental revolution
and then he talked about how he had been
mischaracterized because he had said at
one point that he was seeking a middle
ground in the fight against the planets
warming now
if he had actually been seeking a middle
ground that would be something i think
that most people agree with but he's not
seeking a middle ground
instead he's pushing ever further to the
left he wants to make your life worse
in the name of bill nye the science guy
so bill nye the science guy
cut a video for john oliver because
again everything is about claptor at
this point there's no such thing as
laughter on late night television
anymore
now it is all about i agree with the
cause and so i will pretend this is
funny
bill nye the science guy looking kind of
peaked over here
he did a routine in which he set a globe
on fire and cursed a lot and this was
supposed to convince us
that we need to quote unquote do
something do something
here's bill nye the science guy doing
this routine
here i i've got an experiment for you
safety glasses
on by the end of this century if
emissions keep rising the average
temperature on earth could go up another
four to eight degrees
what i'm saying is the planet's on fire
there are a lot of things we could do to
put it out are any of them free
no of course not nothing's free you
idiots grow the up
you're not children anymore i didn't
mind explaining photosynthesis to you
when you were
12 but you're adults now and this is an
actual crisis
got it safety glasses off
okay hilarious hilarious from john okay
there's one problem
bill nye never actually talks about what
solutions he would recommend
he briefly mentions cap and trade that
ain't gonna cut it
okay the fact is that if the united
states were to cut out all emissions
today
if the united states were simply to stop
emitting according to the
ipcc report the if we cut our emissions
to net zero
and the sensitivity of the climate is
4.5 which is the highest estimate by the
ipcc report
we would cut global warming by 0.062
degrees celsius by 2050
and 0.173 degrees celsius by 2100
that is simply not going to cut it if
you can see this here is a chart
for our subscribers here is a chart of
what
emissions look like right now million
tons of carbon
emitted the united states has been on a
declining trajectory
since basically 2000. china has been
skyrocketing india has been skyrocketing
if you actually wanted to do something
to stop emissions this moment you have
to focus on china and india neither of
whom
is inclined to cut any of its emissions
at the moment
this is really you know nonetheless
yeah the democrats want to make your
life worse
in order to pursue policies that they
have not made even clear this is
i'm saying now the flip of what i said
about trump and tariffs earlier when i
said about tariffs for trump is at least
be honest with the american people what
they are fighting for
if democrats want to make the case for a
policy you have to explain what the
policy does
what the costs are and be honest with us
about it and then we can assess whether
these are good ideas or not
instead you just run around shouting
about the world on fire blowing things
up
alexander ocasio-cortez talking about
the world ending in 12 years and then
claiming yesterday that she wasn't being
literal about that
you know none of that is going to get
the job done you actually want to come
to solutions how about proposing some
actual solutions rather than
sloganeering nonsense
okay time for some things i like and
then some things that i hate so this
weekend
john wick 3 is coming out so i will i
will freely say
i've been wrong about a great many
things in my career happens all the time
i say things i regret i do things i
regret one of the things i regret most
is when i first saw john wick i did not
appreciate it for the masterpiece that
it is
this was a big mistake john wick is
great when i first saw it
i didn't get it because i was like oh so
a dog got killed that's sad
but then i watched it again and i was
like this is terrific
this is terrific so john wick
three is coming out and the original
trailer it's well worth watching it i've
gotten my wife to watch with me
john wick and john wick two which is why
she's a fantastic wife here is what the
original trailer looks like
nice ride thanks how much
excuse me how much for the car she's not
for sale
so it's pretty great and it's pretty
worth watching so go check out
john wick one check out john with two
and i'm gonna go see it this weekend
also keanu reeves seems like sort of a
charming fellow in his interviews
he seems like actually a thoughtful dude
which is kind of shocking okay so
i really enjoy it and i think you will
too take it for what it's worth which is
it starts off really dark and serious
and then it kind of turns into comic
book territory and that's when it gets
fun
okay time for another thing that i like
so another thing that i like today
bill de blasio wants to run for
president and he went to
trump tower for some sort of speech and
he got heckled by the left and it was
hilarious because he is just bad
at running his he he's just bad
at running his city and people in his
own city are yelling at him
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the things i think could be a
grounds for compromise
is physically limiting the speed of
e-bikes
and making them similar to the pedal so
he just got heckled continuously
over and over and over again so you know
that is exactly what bill de blasio
deserves he's a terrible mayor of new
york
and the fact that he has national
aspirations is hilarious okay time for a
thing that i hate
all righty so the view okay megan mccain
has the world's hardest job you know
it's sometimes this job is hard right
very often my job is great sometimes my
job is hard megan mccain has a rough job
pretty much every day she has to go in
on the view and deal with people
who do not understand the points that
she makes think that she's a lesser
person for making them
so she was defending georgia's heartbeat
law a heart of the heartbeat the
heartbeat bill
basically says once a baby has a
heartbeat week six you can't kill it
that's what the heartbeat bill says it
does not criminalize miscarriage
as some lying journalists might say it
doesn't it is not barbaric it is not
dark ages it is none of those things
the bill does not criminalize for women
abortion even
meaning that it criminalizes abortion
for abortion doctors women don't go to
jail under this law
but here's megan mccain defending and
the view losing their ever-loving minds
over all of this
when again all the law is recognizing is
the personhood
the human life that is in the womb and
that it should be protected and this is
simply too much for the ladies of the
view i always feel like pro-life women
are just
completely left out of conversations
like this in one way or another and it
doesn't even occur to her that there are
women like me
out there that don't have a problem so
let's talk about the men instead of the
women
sure let's talk about why are men having
such a war against women
why is the republican party trying to
set women back
50 years or 75 years why do they want us
to go back to the kitchen barefoot and
treat them why
what are they so threatened not what i
want it's a difference of the way you
view
life if you believe it starts at
conception or if you believe that it
doesn't for me i believe that life
starts but they want to regulate my body
why don't they regulate guns for example
they don't do that it's the same people
yeah cheer whoa why don't they regulate
guns they just want to put women back in
the kitchen
barefoot and pregnant uh the fact that
these sorts of slogans are persuasive on
the left
the fact that what megan mccain says
there is eminently correct this is a
difference on the on the worth of human
life the assessment of the worth of
human life
when it begins at least have an
objective debate on that at least have
some sort of discussion
on that rather than just levering
charges levying charges of people
that their that their position is based
on barbarism and bigotry
and yet the fact that joy behar is
considered some sort of intellectual
shining light for
many of the people who watch the view is
pretty astonishing
honestly megan mccain has a rough job
good for her for going into the lion's
den
every day and it is just another
indicator there are badly motivated
people on the left who are more
interested in the slogans associated
with their political positions
than they are in actual discussions
about the issues themselves they'd
rather just shout
they'd rather just shout about how a law
is bad then explain why the law is bad
or
face up to the argument as to why the
law is good
in the first place alright we will be
back here later today with two
additional hours of show
also we'll be back here tomorrow so
we'll see you then i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the ben shapiro show executive
producer jeremy boring senior producer
jonathan haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by adam syavitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by jessua olvera production
assistant nick sheehan the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019. attorney
general william barr appoints a u.s
attorney to look into the origins of the
russia investigation because mueller
time is over and now it's time to pay
the bar tab
democrat representative rashida talib
talks about the calming
holocaust and we might go to war with
iran check it out on the michael knowles
show